one of the world's largest container
ships has turned sideways and blocked
all traffic in egypt's west canal
threatening to disrupt a global shipping
system already strained by the
coronavirus pandemic
tugboats are trying to free the mv ever
given
which sails under the flag of panama it
was carrying cargo between asia and
europe when it ran aground in the narrow
waterway
it wasn't immediately clear what caused
the ever given to turn sideways
several tugboats have been trying to
free the ship and open up the canal
where 12 percent of world trade passes
through
a short while ago i spoke to lars martin
griner an associate partner at hamburg
port consultancy a maritime advisory
firm
and asked asked him just how much of a
hit to global trade the ever given swaz
canal incident represents
uh it's the major trading route
especially for between europe and asia
this is the key lifeline it's where 80
of the cargo containerized cargo moving
between the two
the two areas is it's
it's very very important and it couldn't
have come at a worse time
um coverts had a major effect on
shipping like everything else
we've got major disruption in container
flows around the world
in some ports we've got major major
deficits of containers you can't get the
containers in other court
in other places containers are piling up
because they just can't get them out of
the port for us enough because of covert
so this is just going to add to that um
it really couldn't come at a worse time
for us
right definitely already a troubled time
for the shipping industry
but say you are a ship and you're
blocked from your planned path by the
ever given
what do you do well i think
you know it the it's it's something you
need to look at and react very quickly
to
um the the cause of it is obviously the
the high winds at this time of year in
the area
um i i haven't seen a weather forecast
but i would the first thing i'll do
would be looking at a weather forecast
and seeing
how if those winds are going to continue
um time is of the urgency now because
those winds are going to continue to
push the vessel
more and more horizontal we need to get
target tugs there as quick as possible
to
try and start putting her off try
straightening her up
um i believe they're looking at if they
can't do it quickly
bringing in dredges to start dredging
the sand round everything to try and get
her off
um you're fighting against nature at the
moment um the the the
with the position she's in the with the
streamings and the
the streamings of the water in the in
the canal will be pushing her against
pushing her more and more horizontal
that together with the wind
um you have to remember that these
vessels are essentially big wind
catchers because they're so big and so
square
the wind catches them very hard and as
long as that wind's blowing it's going
to be a very big
mission to try and pull her off looking
at a bit later into the chain
which industries do you think would be
most affected by delayed container ships
i think you'll find that most industries
are be affected for it um
i wouldn't necessarily say to rush out
and go and stock up of
of products in your supermarket but if
you look at the trade between europe and
asia
it is a major lifeline so many of our
products come from there
um everything from hardware to furniture
to
to vehicles um and there'll be a little
bit of everything on board so it's
it's just generally going to delay the
delivery of things to the
um to manufacturers to and to the end
client
um it depends very very heavily on how
long they take together
to get her off but you have to remember
at the moment you've got 50 ships a day
stock
stacking up behind her and looking at
the on the charts a short while ago you
can already
see ships starting to to pull up there
so it's going to cause congestion and
at a lot of ports coming in in a couple
of in the next couple of weeks
which will have just have a flow down
impact on general goods
thank you very much lars griner he's an
associate partner at hamburg park
consulting thank you very much for your
insights today